you know this has been a really wild
ride the past four years of my life it's
been
honestly the best of times and the worst
of times in all ways on
and off this show megan mccain has
officially left
the view on friday the 36 year old
conservative commentator celebrated her
final day on the abc daytime talk show
with
two special guests her mom cindy mccain
and
arizona senator kirsten cinema listen i
am so proud of megan
and i what i look forward to in many
in many ways is to be able to see more
of her and see more
certainly see more of my granddaughter
liberty
i think she's she's done a wonderful job
i love her independence
cindy also spoke out about her late
husband and megan's dad
john mccain her dad would be so proud of
her
and and you know i just i
i wish her the best for in whatever
endeavor she chooses to do but i'm
i'm glad she chose a little bit of
family over
over too much work right now it's
important cindy noted that the late
arizona senator was the one who
encouraged his daughter to join the show
before his death in 2018.
he also wanted her to have an
opportunity to really to really
express herself and and spread her wings
a little more
it was really his suggestion and his
idea that she do this
when offered the job so i i know he and
i know he's very proud of her right now
i know he is
and all that echoes what megan told
viewers last month when she announced
she'd be leaving the long-running panel
show
he said that i could never give up an
opportunity to work on such an iconic
show and to work with whoopi goldberg
and he was right it was one of the last
things he told me to do before he died
on her final day megan also addressed
the audience
and her fellow panelists before the show
wrapped thank you all from the bottom of
my heart and i hope that our executive
producer
brian can forgive me for making his
blood pressure rise for the past four
years
as much as i probably have when megan
announced she was leaving the show in
july
she noted that the pandemic changed a
lot of things for her as she found
herself pregnant and
quarantining in washington d.c she gave
birth to her and hubby ben dominic's
daughter
liberty in september 2020. kovid has
changed the world for all of us
and it changed the way at least for me
the way i am looking at life the way i'm
living my life the way i want my life to
look like when i think about where i
want liberty to have her you know first
steps and her
first words i just have this really
wonderful life here
megan first joined the show in october
2017
after leaving fox news and has been an
outspoken conservative voice on a
primarily liberal panel
i try and just remind myself that i'm
representing 50 of the country
over the years megan has found herself
in heated arguments with
several members of the panel including
whoopi goldberg and
joy behar i'm talking
you missed me so much you missed
fighting with me
i did not miss you i think that's why
people like the show is they know it's
not scripted and they know it's not
we're not being phony and i'm not trying
to placate to an audience
but despite any on-air disputes megan
and joy opened up to e.t
in 2019 about their relationship behind
the scenes
and said it's nothing but love what is
the one thing you want the public to
know about our relationship
that we like each other they keep
writing things about how we can't stand
each other it really hurts my feelings
it genuinely hurts my feelings because
our dressing rooms are next door to each
other and you and i
have the same emotional reactions to
things sometimes in different ways but
we're both upset
equally the equal amount of the same
things and i wish people would give us a
break
for real
you